my grandfather showed it to me and he
was like you don't chew it and I was
like I don't understand eating a food
you don't chew that doesn't make any
sense to me well the not chewing it is
the reason I actually tried it because
it looked terrible to chew but then
people like they're fun you know you get
the lemon in that little cloth you got
the Tabasco sauce that makes you feel
like a giant I do like the lemon in the
in the cloth
and apparently octopus are very very
intelligent beings very intelligent they
are and then that weirded me out they
are kind of going the way of the dodo on
menus I believe for that reason you know
your mom doesn't go hey man barbecue
some octopus you know we got to picnic
Saturday can you get some octopus some
hot sauce already you probably don't
like muscles
is all a 101 for me like I I knew none
of this all I know it looks like doodoo
in a shell and I was like and I'm not
eating that